with the recent spike in Titan sightings
circulating on social media proactive
preparation for a Titan emergence event
is crucial a single towering force of
Nature has the potential to Forever
alter the lives of millions it is our
mission to help you prepare for that
Force the Titan preparedness plan is
your guide to staying safe in the face
of monsters these are the three steps
you need to know one know before you go
identify the location of your nearest
Titan shelter and practice navigating a
Titan evacuation route with your family
on a weekly basis two run and take cover
in the case of a Titan emergence calmly
Sprint to the nearest heighten shelter
if your designated shelter is
inaccessible or at capacity seek the
basement or lowest floor of a nearby
building three stay informed follow any
further instruction from local
authorities and stay informed using your
mobile device television or radio We
Can't Stop a Titan emergence but we can
Safeguard Our Lives join us in building
a safer more resilient Community we are
here to protect
you